[Musique]
vraiment moi j'ai été touché j'ai même
pleuré je vous dis à vous de la super
mec
21e siècle la virilité dans toute sa
splendeur dans toute sa beauté j'ai été
élu et je suis tellement fier tellement
fier de faire partie de ce panel de
speaker de deux hommes deux femmes si
talentueux c'est intelligent si innovant
ans il fit persévérant c'est
extraordinaire je je suis vraiment fier
et l'a donc bon moi je sais plus quoi
dire parce que en fait
bon alors on m'a dit on m'a dit voilà va
falloir que tu as expliqué chez ted
tokoin j'ai fait c'est qui ce monsieur
est au point
je connais pas bon et puis on dit bah
écoute tu vois c'est super préférence ou
alléchant qui viennent par des choses
innovantes choses innovantes franchement
quand tu me regardes bons jeux pas trop
si je représente l'innovation pas alors
je me disais écoute racontons l'histoire
conte comment tu es arrivé là où tu es
là alors juste une parenthèse wake
county papier l'âge on avait vu personne
avec un tapis assez que depuis tout à
l'heure j'ai noté tout ce que mes
collègues ont dit et que j'avais prévu
de dire orgie alors fail dont 10 ah bah
non je te tue dir abbas el abas âge
peut-il dire non plus alors j'avais
prévu de raconter une histoire abbas à
simorre je devais venir danser à balhaf
et j'te plus et ben voila voila c'est
comme quand vous avez dans un buffet
vous savez à plein à manger et puis à la
fin tu te dis bah en fait ils sont
rassasiés ils
il n'y a plus de place donc à tien jure
je te donne le papier maintenant ils
savent pourquoi j'allais le papier mais
je vous allez quand même la voir mon
histoire si ça vous intéresse je passe
ça vous intéresse
[Musique]
vous la raconte
alors en fait non fait pas c'est pas une
histoire ces deux histoires
oui parce que je suis généreuse dessus
quand même togolaise pas décoller quand
même donc à la première histoire c'est
un petit garçon
un petit français qui vit dans une
petite ville du sud de la france qu'on
dise au sud de la france au sud de la
france son papa est ouvrier sa maman et
secrétaire dans une entreprise de la
place
il est fils unique il vit dans un
quartier où toutes les nationalités se
côtoient plein d'enfants autour de lui
bon l'école c'est pas trop son truc mais
ils n ont joué de la guitare il joue au
rugby là plutôt une belle vie et puis il
décide de devenir artiste
il suit son rêve première histoire
deuxième histoire
alors c'est une petite fille ton papa
est togolais sama mois et
guadeloupéennes je me sentais venir là
je pense il est entrepreneur femme amant
et secrétaire de direction dans une
cimenterie de la place
elle est plutôt plutôt bonne à l'école
tout une enfant modèle
et puis elle suit un parcours classique
puis elle se retrouve dans un bureau bon
rien de plus rien d'extraordinaire pour
deux parcours très différents mais qui
un jour se rencontrent un 4 avril 2004 4
4 4
si vous n'avez pas compris jo
ces deux parcours se rencontrent et
comme on dit moi je pense que rien
n'arrive par hasard dans la vie parce
que quand ces deux personnes se sont
rencontrés donc le petit garçon d
jean-luc rabatel mon mari et partenaire
et la petite fille vous l'avez compris
c'était moi on s'est rencontré et on a
décidé de produire ensemble
alors quand je dis produire ce que nous
avons commencé par produire les enfants
[Musique]
et en produisant on vous savez dans ans
s'est entraîné à produire parce que s'il
ya bien quelque chose que l'homme et la
femme d'affaires sont depuis des années
ces fameux s'entraîner s'entraîner
s'entraîner encore et des fois ils font
que s'entraîner d'ailleurs et puis donc
on a fait des enfants et puis on 6ème et
ça c'est finalement c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus facile
donc on se dit c'est très facile de
faire quelque chose aussi complexe et de
si précieux que de fabriquer la vie
mais dès qu'il s'agit de passer à autre
chose ça devient compliqué alors dès
qu'il s'agit de diriger l'entreprise
diriger un pays par exemple cela devient
compliqué de le faire ensemble
mais difficile d'imaginer un homme et
une femme qui dirige un pays je sais pas
moi je vais je vais donner un exemple on
est au togo
en ce moment ce sont les réélections
[Musique]
je prends l'avion demain bon alors et
imagine on prenait juste deux minutes
imaginez deux minutes un pays comme le
togo dirigée par un homme et une femme
tout à l'heure nos amis parlait il
parlait de la différence de
l'acceptation de ce que peut être un
homme et de ce que peut être une femme
imaginez à quel point ça peut être
région je pense juste à question et je
vais s'imaginer et c'est là je vous
parlais de la complémentarité
la complémentarité du genre et l'homme
et la femme ont été créés ils ont été
mis cette thèse c'est pour la raison
enfin moi je pense ainsi non je n'en a
pas bon alors c'est ce que nous avons
fait pour luc et moi bon je l'aï dit on
a d'abord créé des enfants je pensais
que c'était le plus facile mais
finalement peut-être que c'est plus
difficile élever des enfants enfin danse
pour ceux qui en on vous comprenez ce
que je veux dire
et puis nous avons décidé de créer un
autre enfant une société de production
audiovisuelle et est en fait c'est là
que les choses ont commencé à se
compliquer parce qu'il fallait partir de
rien on est vraiment parti de rien pour
construire quelque chose c'est pas si si
vous vous souvenez
alors ceux qui ont à peu près mon âge ma
tranche d'âge dans les années 90
qu'est-ce qu'on regardait la télévision
ici
je sais pas si vous souvenez de
même avant 90 la hora dallas dynastie
donc au gré des blondes cheveux et les
yeux bleus qui raconter des histoires
qui nous racontait qu'il ne racontait
pas notre histoire on comprenait rien
d'autre c'était complètement loin de
notre culture et puis quand on voyait
moins alors soit humour r
soit c'est un noir américain donc c'est
elle et bill cosby show le frais le
prince de bel-air tout ça mais encore
une fois ce n'était pas notre histoire
alors jean luc et moi on se dit ah non
là on a identifié un problème mais qu'
il manque des programmes qui nous
ressemble des programmes qui nous
valorise des programmes dont on est fier
on a identifié deux problèmes
la solution c'est les fabriquer alors
fabriquer des programmes identifiant
dans un environnement où l'industrie
audiovisuelle est quasi embryonnaires ou
il ya pratiquement rien donc je reviens
hall et en 2008 en 2008 derrière
quasiment rien au togo
c'est comme si on vous disait
aujourd'hui je construis une voiture
mais j'ai pas de pièce j'ai pas de
moteur gpad injuste j'ai pas d'industrie
pas d' usine j'ai pas d'ingénieur
j'ai pas d'autoroute en fait vous
reconstruire tout le système
c'est ça que nous avons fait et comment
est ce que nous avons réussi à fabriquer
des séries à succès à fabriquer à lancer
cette industrie audiovisuelle et que ça
fonctionne et parce qu'on s'est basée
sur notre complémentarité
on s'est appuyé sur nos différences
qu'est ce que j'appelle différence c'est
un homme
je suis une femme il est français je
suis togolaise il était artiste j'étais
entrepreneurs issus nique
je suis la grande soeur de deux petits
frères de petits frères
et et à chaque fois ses forces ses parts
dans ses différences on les a
transformés en force et pour moi c'est
simple mon point de vu l'un est ça la
clé du succès et c'est avec ça qu'on
nous devrions tous avancer dans l'eau
dans notre projet d'entreprise dans nos
projets familiaux dans nos dans nos
foyers
nous avons appelé notre notre bébé yobo
studio est ce que vous savez pourquoi
notre société ça paye au studio alors
pourquoi vous savez pour ceux qui sont
pas togolais en mina le yovo c'est le
blanc donc on a pris le yo de nouveau
pour le blanc le bo deux amis bord pour
le noir donc blanc pour jean-luc noir
pour moi et puis c'est un ça faisait un
petit clin d'oeil du noir et blanc pour
le cinéma
voilà on a donné un nom à notre bébé on
sait dire c'est super maintenant qu'on a
fait le plus difficile
on va le faire grandir et bien non ce
n'était pas le plus difficile parce que
une fois que on a fait en armes
on a donné le nom il faut se mettre
d'accord
par exemple pour notre série hospitalité
pour ceux qui la connaissent pas donc
hospitalité c'était une série sur un duo
de médecins la pratiquer la médecine
traditionnelle et puis l'autre la
médecine conventionnelle alors que moi
je disait de moi je suis pour la femme
je voudrais que la femme et les argos
août ific
y en a marre de voir des fans à chaque
fois qu'ils se sont trompés non je veux
qu'elle ait un rôle scientifique et je
veux que pour une fois on voit l'homme
plus en douceur plus en rondeur gens lui
qui va me dire ouais ouais ouais
mais pourquoi
[Musique]
enfin c'est toujours le truc avec jean
et pourquoi
mais alors justement le pourquoi qui
m'énerve à chaque fois c'est le côté
cartésien de jean luc qui apporte une
richesse à notre vieux comme moi je vais
penser au visuel je dire ah ouais moi je
voudrais que je voudrais qu'il soit
beacon stade ce soit joli comme ça j'en
lis quoi faire ouais ouais ouais mais on
va faire comment bah c'est sympa mais
comment ça marche
à la fois moi je vais penser à oui
j'aimerais qu'il dise ice ice ah bah
ouais ouais c'est gentil mais ils vont
dire quand tu l'as tu as pensé et encore
une fois quand j nos différences sont
nos forces
tessa qui je pense en repensant parce
que je vous invite à le faire revenir
sur le pourquoi du comment comment est
ce que vous êtes arrivé là où vous êtes
aujourd'hui je pense que ce qui fait que
la richesse de l'autre diot des cas
chaque fois on a toujours on s'est
toujours appuyé sur nos différences on
est toujours par exemple des confiance
au jugement de l'autre quand il ya des
prises de décision je sais que moi je
vais être référent sur une sur un sur
mes tâches jean-luc pas se mettre en
retrait et va me faire confiance
ur d'autres tâches je vais lui faire
confiance et je m en retrait donc la
confiance au jugement de l'autre au
jugement de l'autre parent dont une
répartition des tâches quand on
contemple et puis surtout accepter
accepter la différence
bon je sais pas moi si pour vous dans
votre dans vos familles si vous regardez
autour de vous souvent se dit oui en lui
les blizzard vient de vous qui parle de
la différence tout à l'heure on réduit
les bizarre je comprends pas j'ai du mal
à travailler avec lui et si on
transforme effet on se disait justement
c'est parce qu les différends qui
m'intéresse et qui va apporter quelque
chose dans mon projet n'est ce pas je
pense sincèrement que si le monde était
dirigée par des hommes et par des femmes
qui le monde avait été dirigé par des
hommes et par des femmes
on n'en serait pas là où on est
aujourd'hui un serment encore une fois
je voudrais que vous vous posiez la
question juste deux minutes
que serait notre pays était dirigé par
un homme et une femme
pensez-y sans se dire c'est un délire
elle reste quoi sérieusement que serait
ce pays est dirigé par un homme et une
femme par angela merkel parce que ce
n'est pas une fin c'est un homme mais
voilà femmes et un homme ans comprend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]